yay for reunions and all but what about
all the creepy crawly monsters slaying
action either that'll happen off screen
which ising unforgivable or the Mind
fler literally sent one minion when it
found out Will's location is that no
it's that other superpower child they
told you about what the hell is this
where you been Hopper said hey 11 I'm so
happy to see you and thank you for
saving us from the bullet resistant face
sucker I was about to start shooting in
vain
strangely Jee come on El that's nasty
your impeccable hair suggests that you
haven't showered since Chicago and even
worse you were just on a
bus stop making that noise it's
unacceptable to Corum in front of any
human being Dustin you sound like Lumpa
wo going through puberty have fun going
down that rabbit hole internet is this
the longest 11 has left her nose bloody
because it feels like it is do you think
if if we got you back there that that
you could close it strip away the Techno
music and the fact that we're watching a
TV show and it's really weird that 11 is
basically ignoring Joyce and randomly
staring off into the middle
[Music]
distance if you're ringing my doorbell
this many times you'd better be holding
a hot as hell pizza and there better not
be pineapple on it I am looking for my
little sister Max their driveway is
pretty dark this time of night sure he's
hot but imagine giving your kid's
location to a barechested Manchild who
just knocked on your door in the middle
of the evening with barely a minute of
hesitation EMP power of boners is strong
but I know for a fact the power of a
mama Bear's protective instinct is a
Little Bit Stronger also we interrupt
your sci-fi psychic monster show to
bring you the start of a really weird
narrative thread that involves
adulterous intentions in an emotionally
and physically neglected housewife
clearly dreaming about having relations
with a minor that's right Billy's only
17 when he first arrives in Hawkins this
is bordering on some taboo fanfic
[__] and I am not not here for it I
said uh demod dogs like demogorgan and
dogs like you put them together it
sounds pretty badass how is this
important right now because Dustin is
the adorable comedic glue that holds the
ship together Hopper feel free to take
on that mantle yourself in season 3 and
see how it works out for you we need to
make the host uninhabitable we need to
burn it out of him to be clear the host
we're talking about making uninhabitable
is a 14-year-old I don't remember seeing
minor minor torture in the Netflix
trigger warnings for this episode take
denfield you're going to see a large oak
tree you're going to swing a right that
road is going to dead end that's about
five minute walk from there the fate of
the world is on the line and you're
expecting me to remember fairly vague
directions with minimal measures of
distance from memory at the very least
you're writing that down for me turns
out I'm actually a pretty damn good
babysitter this one line becomes Steve's
entire narrative Arc over the next two
seasons and I'm here for it the only sin
here is Steve never gets paid for
babysitting after season 2 L come on
let's go go it's time these kids are 12
and 13 maybe hops right and we don't
need to see them kissing yet no this is
on new kid I should have been there why
so you could yell at her Break Stuff and
Trigger another understandable PTSD
meltdown in your adopted daughter
sometimes I feel like I'm like I'm just
some kind of black hole or something
Hopper did a great job of skipping some
emotional earlier between 11 and Mike
but sadly he skipped us right into his
own skippable conversation this is why I
have trust issues Sarah's my girl where
is she she left us the black hole I got
her okay Hopper glad you're opening up
but you must be confusing the sh out of
poor 11 here your daughter died of
cancer which you just described as a
black hole problem is you just described
yourself as a black hole which makes it
sound like either you also have cancer
or you killed your daughter overlay on
to that the idea that 11 has literally
seen paranormal wormholes transport her
to the underworld she may think you're
talking about an actual black hole use
your metaphors with care dude we can't
just bury it like some common mammal
okay it's not a dog are there different
funeral procedures for uncommon mammals
does Dustin have different endof life
rules for reptiles and amphibians after
death the show raises an issue I didn't
expect to need answered but I do I need
answers Dustin so if we get their
attention maybe we can draw them away
from the lab and clear a path to the
gate and if you taken a few minutes to
think about this earlier you could have
come up with this plan while the people
it affects the most were still here so
you didn't have to leave this whole damn
thing to Chance in lazy convenient
writing and who is that
did you see us kids we once again
interrupt your sci-fi psychic monster
show to bring you two num skulls fist
fighting in the kitchen we're 20 minutes
in and there haven't been any monsters
or psychic action yet did stranger
things forget how to you know stranger
things look I understand you got to save
Steve but you do not know how much of
what drug is in that needle they were
using doses big enough to knock out an
otherworldly entity possessing will why
does this show continue to underestimate
how dangerous the concentrated sleep
juice is also Lucille was right there
the great equalizer sure there's a solid
chance of tattis but that sure beats
inducing an accidental coma it's
actually kind of nice nice nice or
landlord renting this sh hole for $2,000
a month is more financial Equity firms
snatch up real estate from lower and
middle class home buyers nice take that
broken American housing market I mean uh
stranger things thing has H well long
enough let's kill the son of a [__]
assuming the gender questionable
parentage of a devil lizard in seven
words or less you let me do the heavy
lifting up front all right you save your
strength till we're below solid plan hop
except you appear to be suffering from
short-term memory loss given that the
violently accelerated metal proved to be
less than effective against the pus pups
from purgatory mere hours ago you're
okay he is
not let me go let me
go the heaters weren't a Max already as
a mom Joyce should really know that only
partially cooking your mind flare
possessed child can lead to nasty food
poisoning it's definitely that or rice
the bottom line is a party member
requires assistance and it is our duty
to provide that assistance listen Dustin
your Sage D and D advice is very in
character but it's hard to swallow after
neither you Mike or Lucas seem to object
or see the inherent flaw in splitting
the party three ways he dog those
suckers got you pretty good huh no hop
they got Bob pretty good this is barely
an a Paar of teeth by comparison did
they not like how he tasted were they
full up on Bob how does he survive this
maybe you could help her lead like a
normal life what skills has Dr Owens
demonstrated to lead you to believe he's
capable of setting up fake identities
for people he's a doctor in a secret
government lab not a black market
passport maker don't go anywhere here
have this gun that is much less powerful
than other guns that we've seen have no
effect on the gor geckos also I know
we're not on the best of terms with Dr
Owens yet but if this was Joyce would
Hopper have left her in the stairwell
hell no instead Hopper here just
quipping away like leaving him here
shouldn't be aing death sentence get
myth don't get M I'm okay nice really
nice Jesus what an idiot listen here you
pubescent plees he wasn't fing faking
just because he's okay now doesn't mean
he didn't have the right to scream at
the sudden shower he just
endured shouting mom instead of stopping
your mom from being choked light her
up I'm in such deep sh team kids light
the fire just in the nick of time to
save Hopper from a fate worse than Bob
think about it they had to come up with
this plan fight off Billy drive to the
right place navigate the tunnels to find
the Hub spray it down pause dramatically
for Steve's one liner light it up and
with no way to communicate what they're
doing to Hopper they get that down to
the
second pH glad will survived the torment
of being possessed now we can live
through the torment of being gay in the
80s closing the gate is a big deal in
all but we're not going to get to see 11
fight a single Raptor Reaper the Mind
flayer has poor resource allocation
skills and we're paying the price
price this is too much handholding for
one
episode start oh [__] off you did not
just bump into the one spooky salamander
that you happened to rear from birth
because you just didn't okay getd come
on the age- old nature versus nurture
discussion was actually solved in 1983
by an annoying kid some nougat in lazy
writing H who knew I wanted to find
something from your past something that
angers you ah sudden Chicago episode
call back DUS on why did they stop
climbing I mean sure it's a long shot
but it's not a bat versus a bunch of
toothy lament lizards long shot wow the
Quasi dimensional quadrupeds multiply
faster than the docki between the Battle
of Winterfell and the Battle of Kings
Landing and I watch too much Game of
Thrones seriously like one maybe two of
these dogs is all it would take but no
the Mind flare is calling everyone back
I'm not rooting for the bad guy I'm just
rooting for
efficiency oh now the guns work on the
satanic Slither skinks now they work
what good is that to Bob L screams while
holding up her hand cliche using two
hands just gets you double sins
fortunately the cataclysm Critters work
just like the bad guys from the first
Avengers movie and all die at the same
time as soon as the gate is closed in
the hero passes out is the next stop
schwarma I'd actually love the next stop
to be
[Music]
schwarma littering sealing The Fallout
zone of an interdimensional hell Rift
with some chain padlocks and a notice do
you want seven seasons of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer I mean of course you do
but these guys shouldn't since the
release of the incendiary tape the once
quiet town of Hawkins Indiana has spent
time in a place it never expected the
national Spotlight even The Duffer
brothers can't last an entire season
without a news position are there no
writers who can create an entire season
without relying on a TV reporter in the
background to deliver expositional
information no just reservation dogs
this Jeep merging into the flow of
vehicles was so smooth it was
orgasmically distracting and don't you
act like you weren't thinking the same
thing pretty sure my football career is
over come on Paul rizer stranger things
didn't in your football career starring
in concussion with Will Smith did they
had a whole year and they forgot to had
school to this Banner or even worse they
decided that Hawkins middle was good
enough but not as much as I love you ly
get out of my room your ability to slam
that door without putting Erica's
orthodontic Journey back several years
proves she is not in fact in your room
ow ow that hurts it's going to be worth
it promise sure you could control how
your daughter looks going to her first
school dance or hear me out you let Max
make her own decisions about her
appearance unless you're just
conditioning her for a world where women
don't get any say in their bodily
autonomy and you're going to slam that
like a
[Music]
lion don't do that okay yeah much better
to wait until you've been dating a while
get married have a few kids and then let
them know who you really are best to
hide all your quirks until they're
forced to stay with you out of sheer
obligation what's in this pure fuel
punch packs hey zombie boy do you want
to dance I know kids are mean and yes
this is mean but none of the people who
tormented me through childhood ever
asked me to dance so I'm sitting this
for being unrealistic and definitely not
out of jealousy show makes me sit
through a full minute of Dustin being
rejected on the Dance Floor wrapped in
what was already a sufficiently
torturous 8 minutes of high school dance
flooring ending that sophomore slump
strong aren't we stranger things hey
want to dance pity dances come on let's
go but who will be in the punch bowl
it's the 80s someone's totally going to
spike it probably a teacher it's worth
every breath I take to remind you at
every opportunity that the police song
currently playing is not a love song and
if you are of a differing opinion please
don't stand so close to me a they got a
dance that's cute they'll each get an
adorable little memory to accompany all
that physical and emotional Trauma from
being attacked by interdimensional
monsters you know we often see buildings
in the upside down that have a
counterpart in our world but my main
curiosity is when did the buildings in
the upside down get built this season
was set 1984 so if you build a house in
1985 in Hawkins would it automatically
get a parallel version of itself in the
upside down or was there a cut off for
these things to appear like nothing
after 1980 gets to exist in the upside
down these are the answers we need in
season 5
people you got renewed for a third
season we get
it all right now let me tell you
something I'm a bad father do you know
what the definition of insanity is no do
you yes it's the inability to relate to
another human
being now wipe yourself off you're
bleeding I'm Nancy's mother but you're
you're so you're so thin we can't just
bury it like some common mammal okay
it's not a dog you're not cheddar you're
just some common [__] that's one point
of view from a certain point of
view I am going to beat the holy
fuing FY out of one of you expecto
patronum you held on to it as long as
you could didn't you